hi everyone I'm David Griffin now
Michael Medina they were to bring you
arrow season 2 finale review season 2
episode 23 unthinkable we believe we
missed unthinkable they're gonna be our
last review for quite some time yeah
probably til October I'm guessing it
next year it's sad arrow is finished
it's come to a conclusion for now for
this season Nick I think it went out in
style I'm gonna go in and start by
saying I think it went out in style I
think it did what any good finale should
do didn't leave you like oh like any
chance the fingers still kind of wrapped
the overall story being riddled this
season right so i thought it was thought
it was good and there's a lot of stuff
to dive into there's some stuff it was
it was a good episode was a really good
episode you know there's always a little
quirks here and there but overall I
think Mike and I both really enjoyed it
had fun watch and had fun talking about
it while we were watching it so first
impressions Mike what you think about it
um again just like what you said I
thought they did a really good job and
you know wrapping up this story but like
you know giving you a glimpse at the to
like what season three is gonna be about
um overall a lot happen it's all I got
it's just like last week I guess it's
like where do you start with an episode
like I know where to start let's start
talking about it I can't say everybody's
maybe three or four commenters like
David I can't believe that you fell for
that whole gimmick when Thea was a
shitty you know there was a guy behind
oh I don't think there was somebody
behind I didn't see anyone but I just
say bye behind who did she shoot she's
really Merlin gosh I'm Malcolm Merlyn
got a little something like Kevlar he
had Kevlar you know so I think I was
right I'm not always right you know I do
make this day to enjoy a lot of a choice
but I'm gonna enjoy this better I knew
that she shot no I didn't know that for
sure but that was a good scene I
actually of all the people well let's
call them weaker characters okay when
I'm gonna say we could characters I mean
Laurel who's struggling everybody's in
the comments asking her to be killed off
but let's let's give Laurel chance for
next season Thea I think her arc hasn't
been the strongest but you know from the
beginning to the end I actually liked
her I thought sure maybe her story out
of laurels has the most potential for
next year yeah her going off with
Malcolm at the end was interesting I
don't know what that's gonna I was
definitely more interesting than laurels
yes yes it's kind of like last week's
you when I mention that you know maybe
we might see the two of them hook up so
now you know maybe he might like take
her under his wing and like that it's
probably what's gonna like he it was so
nice at the end with her getting that
limo and he was just sitting there like
muhaha people smile on his face he's a
good actor so I'm happy to see what's
gonna happen at the M yeah you know she
you know what's his name well I guess he
could be red arrow now I guess we'll get
into that but I mean Thea could turn
into something I assume that he's gonna
train her yeah I mean he knows he was
part of the League of Assassins so he
knows some moves well and the thing is
too I mean she's in a real vulnerable
state right now she's like anybody can't
trust them absolutely when she thought
she can maybe let Roy back in and stuff
and she discovered that he still had her
know some arrows and a quiver and stuff
and she's like no that's it so again in
this vulnerable state Merlin could maybe
manipulate her yeah you know and maybe
turn her against ya which would be kind
of cool that's gonna be good I mean and
then you know you look at I mean man
this is so much going on in this episode
so we get in the beginning at least
towards me to the episode the League of
Assassins shows well a section of the
League of Assassins nieces crew or
entourage shows up with Sarah like to
say laughing when I love that scene when
ISA introduces herself to felicity she's
like you know I'm the daughter of racial
googled heir to the deer to the deal I
do I'm Felicity Smoak MIT 2009 that was
fun that was a great yeah it was can't
be but it was perfect I mean it were it
was perfect and I like that uh i mean i
think nice i think Christina law has
cast perfectly for this again another
Spartacus alam so it's nice to see her
again will be obviously seen more of her
next season which is good but yeah just
such good banter in that scene it's nice
to see their small group of assassins
and helping out you know we talked about
last week's episode about how I see that
in the preview though those yeah then
marching together for the big fight at
the end which was cool to see no it's
great i'm in action a lot of action
scenes take place I mean we should
probably talk about I guess the first
major one is when they they tech Queen
industries and their offices there like
that and I'm not gonna lie i thought
that fight was gonna go on a little bit
longer but sweet but um and you know our
girl summer glau man yeah she's done I
know I and I guess you never both kind
of like we didn't say it right away we
were like
no if we like that I mean well have to
go on IMDb and i'm sure you guys will do
that when you look in this review and
see maybe she has some projects coming
up I mean pilot season is on its way
they could be shooting for next year
already so maybe she has something
planned she's like nah I can't stick
around because she was in the beginning
I really liked your character yeah
Isabel rochev was great then she was
gone yeah and every week during this our
reviews I kept asking where's her some
of you got annoyed with that but I said
you know what I'm gonna ask every single
time until she comes back and now she's
gone I thought I didn't get a complete
story with her and it was a nice little
twist making her ravager and stuff I
mean maybe some of you guys didn't like
it I know we were pretty cool with it
like that yeah but again like I liked
her is ravaging I would like to sing a
little more of her yeah you know but I
mean you know I guess it was kind of
cool to cuz Justin ISA basically you
know kind of like driving home Oh i lo
this is what you got it you gotta kill
people this is why your cities right
right and it's it's always one of those
tough questions because in comic books
you have guys like Bruce Bruce doesn't
kill you know you have Superman you know
doesn't kill but I like you know I like
little flexibility you know Wally Wally
well getting look in the head of myself
you say while I get my head sell for the
flash but Oliver is not the punisher
he's not Frank Castle so he's not gonna
just kill everybody he does have a
conscience but i liked it i think the
end was good with him was Slade putting
slate away you know in on the island
which is ironic putting them back on the
island in this new max security prison
that Argus is created well and that goes
back to like the episode when Moira was
killed in a locker like you know I know
we'd mentioned like no should Oliver
kill again surely kill right later and I
was like basically I I thought I kind of
liked that conflict you know cuz this is
a guy that was a cold-blooded murder
Oliver you know and I Caillat told him
he's like look I I made you exactly you
are I know your killer yeah but you know
what was cool about that is that the end
he's like basically you turned me into a
hero cuz i'm told me that you taught me
right away you know that I could you
know get these results without having to
murder anyone ya know and I liked seeing
that struggle you know with Oliver like
you know he's tenting he wants to kill
but there's always whether it be
Felicity or a be even Diggle kind of
like no you know this is the person that
you're meant to be 00 ever got we got to
talk about diggle's papa I'm proud
none of that storyline are the father uh
I can remember the actress's name she's
a she was in walking dead she was the
governor's yeah mmm girl for a little
while yeah in this last season of the
walking dead and she comes back you know
diggle's ex-wife yeah they used to be
married yeah ex-wife comes in you know
looking all hot with her outfit on the
bazooka you know blowing up buildings
doing what she does and then by the way
by the way I'm here he's like oh there
she is thanks for saving our lives which
is funny and then Amanda Waller drops it
it's like Oh what do you got you know
something got brewing in there got a
girl or boy and it's like congratulation
you know what he says look it's just
like what that in my kid you know oh
it's nice to see that Diggle has been
doing something you know off camera if
you know what I'm saying you know what
I'm saying yeah he's doing something off
camera so that was nice and give Diggle
something hopefully poor Diggle will
have more to do than go to big belly
burger every week and yeah and
impregnate women and impregnate women
that's a little you know I got a game so
hopefully he'll have more to do but we
got to see more a little bit of the
Suicide Squad not all of them yeah I
guess he dead shot I love their
relationship Diggle and Deadshot
relation like you can give Diggle and
etch out their own like a couple
episodes Bruce's and that would be fine
yeah because the whole like you know he
wants to kill um what it's like they
kind of work well together yeah it is
really yeah it makes for an interesting
relationship it was good i mean and then
you know even amanda waller again it
looks like we're gonna get more of her
yeah next year I go your next history we
knew was miserable because there was
some some beef like when they first met
like oh I don't think either you ever
see me again or something and we know
Oliver has to go back to the island even
though we see him in Hong Kong it in the
episode so you know get to our theories
about that at the end but you know let's
talk about let's see what else do we
have I mean just like the big fight the
big ND like the setup and seen between
especially olicity fans eliciting Oliver
Felicity a little guys talk about that
little tease well that was big I mean I
know when we were watching we were just
like yeah like because I wait a minute
a 10 yeah I mean they know kind of
teasing it since since last season yeah
I guess you know them but this season
was when things really kind of you know
went full steam ahead but like you know
obviously you could see in her face that
she believed every single word all right
so yeah but I mean it made sense and and
you actually called it too cuz you know
just like you know maybe he's you know
he remembers that you know slated bugged
his house maybe this was his way to kind
of cuz he was like he's like it Danny's
like do you understand yes like yeah and
I was like wait a met seemed a little
didn't kiss or anything and I don't know
I feel about that I didn't like well I
don't say I didn't like I just kind of
felt bad for Felicity's at the end of
the island she was like well you almost
made me believe yeah what you said he's
like yeah they got lucky my god you did
alright chatter that like its kind of
walked off and he's like that's enough
for me like wow cuz I don't know
Felicity's gonna be able to be with
Wally because while he's got the nose
Barry hey I'm sorry hey Wally i'm
getting my comment yeah I said Barry
Allen cuz iris is it yeah it's gonna be
you know in the flash theory so yeah
poor I'm explicity gonna date break I
mean and Diggle is gonna be a Papa but
maybe you know maybe we can have a cup
of girls I don't know they could do it
he's a popular so um that's going on and
then well and then there's Sarah
obviously clear yeah those there goes we
kind of see we've been talking since the
very first episode of season about
Laurel and the possibility of whether or
not she'll be Black Canary you're not
right and you know some people some of
you guys think maybe she might go Sarah
Micah kill daughter Laura will kind of
take the mantle I don't know I'm on the
fence who knows because I do i do like
Sarah and as black and Aryan that's kind
of fun but there's a little tease i
don't know if it's a little bit of for
shellac jacket or yeah it was not a fan
yeah she gives to the black leather
jackets like oh it's you know so my only
issue that i know a you view voice is
concerned i know some some of the
viewers hear voices concern is that i
don't know if i buy a laurel as black
hair she doesn't know she's earned it
yeah meant we know she knows how to
fight she has some self-defense classes
her dad was a cop but she wasn't trained
by League of Assassins she wasn't
trained by destro like Oliver was so
it's like I don't know she could be as
an effective maybe she'll learn I mean
now that she knows who Oliver is maybe a
little train her and that's the thing
and who knows this could all just be
like these last two seasons laurels
right could have just been set up for
maybe her ultimately becoming
because for her to be Black Canary I
mean again it's kind of like what we saw
all of a gold if you had to go through
something yeah Sarah had to go through
something yeah become who you know they
ultimately became so we're gonna kind of
maybe see Laurel maybe probably because
I mean we saw her deal with you know the
fact that a her sister came back from
the day you know she had this drug and
alcohol addiction and she's been kind of
like the damsel in distress for overall
yes gonna scream though it would be
interesting it and I know we've been
complaining for a long time about
laurels you know lack of story right so
maybe again this is just set up maybe
next year we'll see her play a bigger
role maybe we'll see a little bit more
you know good drama happening to Lauren
what I mean right it kind of built her
up and maybe she can still be you know
canary who knows so Lisa you know i i'd
like to know specifically from the
writers maybe even if Talia just doesn't
exist in this timeline I mean cuz Nisa
is she keeps saying she's the heir to
the demon yeah you know and we know in
the comic book she's the illegitimate
daughter of course this is not the comic
book this is arrow so with a pick and
choose you know they don't always use
the same they don't you know it's not
gospel necessarily so I'd be here see
what they're gonna do with that I can't
help but wonder maybe because of Talia's
such a clever close connection to Bruce
oh yeah that universe that maybe they'd
rather leave that alone which is good
that's fine because their own this can
be their own daughter of race doesn't
have to hang the name doesn't really
matter she can basically embody Talia so
if she wants who she looks like I mean
she'd be a great tile you're saying
she'd make a great Psylocke I think she
made pretty good marble yeah so um yeah
I mean that that was all really good i
really liked her i'm can't wait to see
more of her so many curves i want to see
more of an i guess we're starting to
wrap up trying to go towards the end
here so start talking about I guess
let's see where it's ended I mean where
do we see we see Oliver we see that what
no no wait wait let's like what the
fight scene let's talk about the fight
scene the last fight scene between
Oliver and destro gráfica what you think
about that whole cutting back and forth
I well yeah we were watching I was like
you know I really loved how fluid it was
yeah you know it really just seemed like
one fight but I like that it was like
two fights you know five years apart
right off tonight you can kind of see
and I know you were mentioning you can
kind of see like you know Slade fighting
with me Rikuo right and without which
owes Oliver beats on both times yeah
he's a much better fighter when we see
him now than he was then he still even
though Slade comes back to LA
me but he's a bugs a good fighter and it
was wrong in the end because you can
kind of well first of all you see how
Slade gets his eye poked out yeah that
was a kind of see you know the
difference and again going back to the
whole light though conflict killing and
knocking you see like where you know
Oliver's mindset was at five years ago
right when he just kind of ditches the
cure when I just stabbed in the eye then
you see how like how he's mature he
wasn't thinking long term he wasn't do
think that slave would create this army
of you know exactly uh but he's learned
yeah is kind of cool it was a great
thing and then it's funny we see Sarah
you know falls down our guests you know
get sucked down the ship the same way
she did when the when the you know the
first timer robert wiene yacht got
nighters like no sorry what I'm really
hoping this is one of my hopes for next
season I would love to see a flashback
with her in the League of Assassins like
her meeting Nisa them falling for each
other to get a little lesbian thing
going on it's all good like I'd love to
see I'd love to see her back so I know
we always get Oliver flashback since
this cast is expanding I'd love to see
Sarah get a flashback next season and
that's the thing like people like Slade
like my up in it and Sarah they played
huge rolls this season how big of a role
they can play next season though because
who's there the villain exactly i can't
see Slade right I could see maybe
appearing next year definitely not being
the focus and I wouldn't want that any
right you know what I mean and with
Sarah again like with her taking off
like it just seems like how do you fit
that in cuz she's gone it would be a
little too convenient for like two weeks
later she's back again right oh she she
I'd wanted to stay away for a while the
thing is will you have all these players
cuz Malcolm merlyn's back he's back so
you have we know Rachel Ghul is out
there and he's obviously would be the
biggest villain we can probably think of
at least it cuz this arrow isn't going
supernatural no cuz the arrow in the
comic books has like like guys like
Robin Hood but I mean you have like you
know the all these like medieval Merlin
like a more magical creatures we're
probably this is more kind of like
Christopher Nolan outlook on the DC
comic books I'm gonna be more I think
you're right i think rachel well again I
don't know if we'll see race right but
the League of Assassins I think will
play a big role and maybe that's how we
will see moresee r because earlier in
the year one more
morning scare is Merlin whole like you
know ratio ghum brings up his name
obviously he has a connection to raise
yeah so if Merlin I would imagine murder
would probably be the main villain
frozen I'd imagine we would see some
League of Assassins which would be great
because more is out of the way yeah and
what's curious to me is we know that I
know he loves his daughter don't doubt
that but it's like what is his motive
because he had that really evil grin
yeah in the limo status like she's all
kind of like nervous and awkward he's
all like whoa I'm you know I just wonder
what he's thinking Merlin's not a good
guy I'm not a good not good even when
after Thea shoot something like you know
you basically had something that Tommy
didn't write right no and I see that in
you now I won't embrace it I'm gonna
bring that out of you so you know yeah
he's not gonna father the father of the
year awards no im sue no but he's got
some kind of agenda and Diggle and
Felicity we kind of leave them where
they've always been Felicity's confused
not sure if Oliver likes or not you know
poor girl and that's the thing sorry to
cut you know yeah Felicity I'm curious
to see where she gonna go because Diggle
kind of has his own thing I don't know
you got a kid on the way you know he's
kind of he's kind of with the Suicide
Squad kinda he knows he likes that show
going on Felicity I feel is kind of
stuck in the middle right now and I
really hope she doesn't kind of fall in
it rut that like Laurel or Thea kinda
because you just wanted to be the geeky
girl go to computers the whole time like
I'm nice to her to have a story and I
don't I can only take so much of the
good the t's between the will they won't
go you're the wrong it gets old after a
while so it's like you know if you
wanted to get together haven't get to
get right you know what I mean it just
don't continue to tease that get old
after a while here's a little that yes
the donation see what happens to them
there were left us Amanda Waller that's
gonna be interesting story because we
know her Ali have a pass yeah we're
gonna see what that is and we know
Oliver also goes back on the island
because you seem to be the season one
he's got the the beard he looks just
like arrow kind of like a rougher
version of Errol from the comic book so
it's gonna be sure to see what does he
do in hong kong is he gonna work for her
i'm assuming there's gonna be a
relationship you know Oliver sleeps
around at abees so there's gonna be some
romance why does he go back to the
island yeah how many more you know all
this dish so there's a lot of good stuff
this finale wrapped most of the stories
up but less it open for another one and
I'm so glad they didn't kill man who
banette because he's been such a good
you know maybe great you know be cool
all right I guess what kind of going on
a tangent here but we've got to talk
about it there's a new son of batman
story out right now we're not new it's a
new DC animated movie it's based off
Grant Morrison's classic story and that
story Deathstroke worked for ratio cool
he was his protege and he's angry and
upset because Damien is now that the
heir to the throne but Deathstroke
thinks that that should be him and he's
he's pissed and all that kind of stuff
so I wonder if this is a way because he
stuck could race or Nisa maybe get at
him while he's in that prison and maybe
you came out break him out yeah would be
kind of cool every kind of interesting I
don't know cuz again he is such a gay
character but just like kind of
something that I said a couple weeks
back you don't want to over use a
character you know what I mean because
then it's just like all right well it
seems a little unbelievable that's
really convenient that he gets you know
broken out of prison or whatever yeah
but I do like that there and I would
like to see something like that low yeah
you know dumb boy like a machine so I
mean you know that was a finale I mean
lot going on a lot of things that we
covered about everything that we could
you know let her know if you you know
about the beginning there with a you
know Thea shooting you know Malcolm
Merlyn you know I thought I forget to
that right I did you know I have to say
that again every people you guys called
me out saying I fell for some ploy which
I was i thought i did was like well
maybe i did fall for maybe I am it's not
observant so no I'm just joking anyway
uh you know real quick this one more
thing I'd say overall I'm really like
you and I first you know did a review
for this oh yeah I'm sorry yeah we got
to get far before we go we gotta give
her overall impression yeah yeah about
the season I'm sorry we talked about
things we're looking forward to seeing
just like things were excited for and
overall though I have to say as a whole
this was definitely one of the best
seasons of a TV show on it and I'm not
saying it's the greatest season and they
know but it's definitely one of the best
overall well-put-together seasons
because we owe at the start of the
season we were talking things about like
filler episodes and they're being way
too many episodes and it's ordered to
never wanted to but even I know like a
couple weeks back we kind of you know
kind of differed on that one you know I
enjoyed it you were just like whatever
but overall I think they did such an
amazing job tell me I loved season one
and I thought they'd built on that
beautifully in season two like right
from the get-go like the first however
make like
eight episodes just like every single
episode had yelling at TV I blown away
so I mean I just I absolutely from start
to finish loved this season I I loved it
I agree it was a great season I can't
wait i hope that and it's gonna be a
different team but the writers that are
gonna be on the flash i hope they can
keep that energy going i'm excited to
see what's gonna happen because you
don't want the sheen the flash either no
I wanted to copy it yeah I don't want to
be the exact same thing cos Phi should
be a little bit lighter the kids kind of
Goofy's not like you afraid oldest
really I mean he's not gonna be like
that so um you know all good things come
in and I'm excited to see what's gonna
happen I mean the universe is expanding
its getting bigger we didn't see much
name who's locked up in prison Huntress
yeah we still there you know somewhere
locked up so we'll see what happens with
that more the Suicide Squad to come
flash is gonna have his own show it's
getting good we're gonna see what
happens Wally beery I'm gonna say Allah
quality manali we're gonna shoot happens
to Oliver in Hong Kong hanging around
with Argus oh yes Argus yea and all that
so that's going to be good so as always
you know thanks for joining us for this
season you know it's going to be a
sizzle reel at comic-con it'll be mom's
probably in July we'll see what's going
to help me there to review it with their
review it will give your view that
sizzle reel when it comes up in a few
months but thank you for joining us we
appreciate all the support all the
comments all the loves has been a fun
journey you know these last 23 episodes
23 hours over 6 1 33 but it's been fun
and we enjoyed it so I'm as always you
can come chat with us at thank yo calm
or on this YouTube page think hero pro
all of us are on Twitter Dennis Michael
and myself r on Twitter here at think
hero I'm at Griffin de and I'm at mr.
Michael Alexis and we also have a
Facebook page that's facebook.com slash
think your fans we should have like that
like the g-tube page as well subscribe
spread the word social media let us know
what you thought of this wonderful
season and give us your predictions
that's we want to hear what you think is
going to happen in season 3 of arrow and
until next time do not feel your cities
and we'll see you soon
you